[Música]
[Aplausos]
teorias de conspiração dos nós já
ouvimos falar dirija com inspiração
uma delas é da e diria até à pana
de que forma da terra é um disco mas que
os seus pessoas que seguem essa idéia
reconhecem que os outros planetas tem
forma esférica o que a ida do homem à
lua foi falsificado tantas fotografias e
os filmes que existem são são
falsificados
no entanto existem evidências do de
presença humana no solo lunar
o outra teoria da conspiração estamos a
ser escravizados
há milhares de anos por uma raça de
reptilianos
no entanto há outras teorias da
conspiração que são mais fáceis de gente
acreditar e aceitar e provavelmente
muito alguns nós acreditam na algumas
que eu vou falar de seguida
algumas são coisas que os organismos
geneticamente modificados outros com a
indústria farmacêutica
outras coisas cenas outra escola náutica
particulares kent wells e conquistas
não estou a falar daquelas polêmicas
informadas que surgem nas redes sociais
sobre cepisa detran na zonal nariz que
eu vou falar do assunto
o contrário bastante sério aconteceu
nesta campanha das eleições republicana
das eleições americanas de 2016 em que o
site de teorias da conspiração
promoveram a idéia de que o equipa dos
democratas estavam a operar em segredo
uma rede pedófila em restaurantes
americanos movimento das pessoas que
acreditavam nessa cidade ficaram
indignados e certo dia um em vidro
foi uma mão um restaurante uma pizzaria
entrou armado e começou a disparar
felizmente não matou ninguém
no entanto que o machucou não encontrou
nem a cabo onde estariam as crianças não
encontrou qualquer pessoa é nessas
condições tanto foi apanhado e foi foi
preso
nós quando olhamos para o céu
de vez em quando vemos riscos brancos
são raças conexão são formados quando as
condições estão reunidas do emirado tem
temperatura e altitude
no entanto os ceos das pessoas que
seguem sentido as pessoas dizem que na
realidade são caixas químicos que são
criados deliberadamente são debitadas
liberadamente para nos ensinar e para
nos controlar as vacinas ou uma
associação a idéia de que assim né a
vacina tríplice é causa autismo foi
criada esta associação entre esta vacina
eo autismo
no entanto propor as instituições foram
fazerem irão acusar científica que fosse
fazer a investigação e que não usar
esses casos foram feitos muitos ensaios
para verificar se isso é verdade o anel
ea cunhada científica concluiu que não
há qualquer relação
neste processo o jornalista estiveram
emprestados foram fazer a investigação
jornalística sobre o caso eo juiz tem
particular percebeu que para lá ainda
verão na fraude científica com os
artigos publicados que havia outros
interesses por trás
havido falta de ética né não neste
processo o médico envolvido o equil
porque publicou este artigo na revista
lancet na revista médica é muito
conceituada e o jornalista empreender
quando foi investigar isto foi comparar
a informação estava no artigo científico
com os relatórios cliente e logo
verificou que a informação não bater
certo também verificou que conseguiu
descobrir ao longo da investigação que o
advogado tenha queria processar em a
indústria produzir a vacina tríplice que
tinha pago previamente ao ano o iof para
falsificar os dados para demonstrar que
esta associação descobriu também que o
andré o action alguns meses anos de
emitir o comunicado à imprensa dizer que
faz desta associação entre a vacina ea
doença que o próprio tinha patenteado
uma das cenas simples só contra o
sarampo
a vacina tríplice fosse convidada do
mercado era a vacina única do seram
ficaria ser vendido é importante eu tive
eu iria ganhar dinheiro com isso o
direito quanto essa história com essa
história foi foi dada a conhecer ao
público
o andré foi a tribunal e perdeu a sua
licença poder exercer a medicina no
reino unido e teve que se exilar nos
estados unidos onde foi reclamado como
herói que estava sempre cita os
cientistas e pela indústria farmacêutica
mas na realidade o verdadeiro herói da
história foi o jornalista por um dia
esta é a parceira iria da conspiração
mais pessoas acreditam que a indústria
farmacêutica que tem na sua posse há
cura para várias doenças
em particular a cura para o cargo que só
não quer dar a conhecer às pessoas
porque porque não quer perder nenhum
a questão é crescer a indústria começa a
ter essa cura ela iria beneficiar disso
economicamente queria vender essa cura e
iria lucrar muito isto é que as pessoas
tenham estes aios e desconfie da
indústria farmacêutica e passem a
adquirir a a adquirir procurar curvas
próximas doenças em mesinhas como por
exemplo consumir o limão para
já o campo que o movimento não cura
organismos geneticamente modificados as
pessoas têm que sair dos organismos
geneticamente modificados que possam
causar cancro esta ideia foi também num
artigo publicado pelo será on-line este
caso ficou conhecido com câncer aline
por causa do investigador em que é eu
fazia esta associação escreveu um artigo
e por e estes foram os resultados
a questão é que o esse artigo científico
tem é assunto lojas muito graves e
quando há equipas dos laboratórios
independentes foram testados por com
sugestões e dúvidas na equipe
os cientistas querem mesmo comprovar
isto faça tentar fazer aplicação de
ficção e não conseguiu obter estes
resultados tanto foi provado contra ele
é falso com carteira falsa e tem essas
conclusões não não é um canalha
depois é preciso compreender um
carismático e perceber que organismos
geneticamente modificados em quase todos
os alimentos que nós comemos porque
desde a história desde o início da
humanidade que se dedicou à agricultura
e à pecuária
nós somos selecionando as
características que pretendem das minhas
características possíveis
fomos a assinantes essas variedades ao
longo do tempo e ao longo de várias
gerações fomos tendo fundos a pena é que
essas variedades pretendemos obter
formas diferentes ao longo do tempo os
nossos antepassados saber então vamos
fazer o organismo geneticamente
modificado que estavam alterar o genus
dos alimentos no século 21 a função de
biotecnologia o que permitiu fazer foi
termos alimento é termos um processo
mais seguro mais rigoroso e mais rápido
mais rápido porque não quisemos pra
várias gerações para obter essas
variedades mais rigoroso possível
escolher o gênero específico está a ser
alterado e mais seguro porque antes
destes produtos serem comercializados
são amplamente de toda a tensão
amplamente investigadas prevê para
garantir sua segurança
no entanto essas teorias da conspiração
dizem a gente às vezes o valor do modo
muito leve
é verdade que elas têm consequências não
são inócuas por exemplo no caso dos
organismos geneticamente modificados
vou é que o organismo
não possam ser produzidos andar escassez
de nutrientes ou é o andar é um dos que
eles não são os mais aptos para serem
cultivados e tantas podem ficar uns
podem motivar nesses locais porque cria
uma opção pública
além do mais já houve confrontos físicos
entre ativistas e os agricultores
antes tem consequências também no caso
das vacinas do receio das vacinas leva a
que as pessoas deixem de vacinar
isso faz com que doenças que estavam
controladas ou algumas totalmente
dedicadas como é o caso dos eua em
portugal no ano passado volta a estar
ativas
então é preciso pensar nas causas e nem
assim possíveis soluções para esse
problema
uma das causas teve com desconfiança nas
instituições sociais confiam dos
cientistas desconfiam dos médicos confia
inclusive da imprensa no caso da
imprensa é ainda uma das profissões em
que os analistas têm que mais podemos
confiar porque tem são obrigados a
responder um dever deontológico e então
que as funções é que podemos ter é temos
pra ficar a informação que recebemos
desconfiar dela e verificar temos
podemos consultar sites de verificação
de facto o chamado cheque em como por
exemplo em portugal temos dois bons
exemplos disso o jornal online
observador tem uma secção uma comuna de
facto check in e também um projeto de
160 polígrafo que também fazem esse
serviço
depois porque nós somos facilmente
enganados e têm de estar conscientes
disso não são enganados pelos outros
principalmente enganados por nós mesmos
renato que nós mesmos porque somos
facilmente privados é ir ao encontro dos
nossos próprios viés pessoais um deus e
houve a confirmação
nós temos mais facilidade em aceitar uma
ideia com a qual já vai ao encontro do
que acreditamos é do contrário e isso é
prejudicial porque a gente pode haver
uma idéia uma notícia falsa israel
enquanto que nós acreditamos então o que
vemos por aceitar esta notícia
ela também temos tendência a acreditar é
é temos tendência a ser um certo
conforto e daí por que alguém por trás
de controlar as coisas quando a
realidade é muito mais durante a crise e
há poucas pessoas são pessoas que têm
controle não têm a situação da nossa
volta é aleatória é e portanto não há
ninguém controlar a situação e nós temos
dias têm essa consciência que nós
podemos atuar no transporte dos outros e
porque esta é uma questão social é uma
questão social porque quando as pessoas
acreditem nessas teorias da constituição
tem tendência a ser inicialmente um
núcleo reduzido começam a sair do ar
começa a inflação entre elas ea
partilhar e criar seu próprio espaço os
seus próprios grupos ea partilhar essas
informações nesse grupo que depois disso
vão os grupos vão aumentando em número e
vamos passar nessas essa informação essa
desinformação ao longo do tempo
então nós nos vemos lá essas pessoas não
devemos afastar dessas pelo contrário eu
acredito que nós vimos aproximar delas
em vez de pensarem que eu quero fazer é
estranho senhora é uma pessoa
sensacional de dez diferentes milícias
são seres humanos temos conversar temos
de alugar filmes bateria da strans
partilhá las e diego confrontar nos com
a ideia de frente e tentar perceber
porque é que esta espécie daquela
maneira e tentar apresentar de provas no
sentido contrário para ver se conseguem
perceber que estão a acreditar é
desinformação estão teoria da
conspiração
eu acredito estou convencido disto que é
possível num futuro próximo a gente
deixar de haver dirija com inspiração
para isso é preciso fazer check in se
concentrar nossas forças é preciso
duvidar é preciso ter pensamento crítico
é preciso começarmos uns com os outros
estou disposto a criar é contribuir para
esta situação todos podem fazer minha
parte e vocês estão dispostos a fazer a
vossa
[Aplausos]